were there some big accidents on set we
had three
yeah we had three we got lucky ronnie
perlman went down hard do you know ron i
know him from conventions
yeah he he he's the best he's really
cranky but i love him was he cranky on
set
uh
sure i mean
the the first he looks like frankie
right
but the last couple you know when you
know you're gonna die or you don't like
the writing or yeah he became cranky but
i think we all had a bit of crank in us
yeah right but yeah i know he went down
hard and and i was right beside him when
i got off my bike like a horse i just
got out so fast told him not to move not
to move lay there lay there the
ambulance came and he turned out to be
all right a lot of legions and scrapes
and then mark boone jr booney
we could have lost him we were doing a
scene we were chasing the russians of
course we were chasing the russians well
wouldn't it be
you know who wouldn't be and so we're
chasing the russians and he had this
old
late 90s harley
with these ape hangers really tall it
was really hard to negotiate and
navigate it's a tough bike to ride and
he's a great rider and we went around a
corner too many rocks and he slid and he
slid hard and he missed a big big
boulder and uh
he was up for a couple days and then
tommy yeah i could go on but we we were
all right no one got seriously hurt we
were very lucky right